- So first of all,
thank you for letting me
be your neighbor and bring you some cake.
- Thank you so much.
- It's a really good cake.
- I took the Bundt home.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I put ice cream on top of it.
(audience gasps)
- Oh my gosh
you're my husband.
- It's too much.
That was too much sweetness.
I shoulda just left it
at the Bundt.
- Okay you're not my husband.
(laughing)
He can totally.
He literally will bring
a mixing bowl full.
He's the most fit-looking,
skinny individual.
I wanna cut him in his sleep.
(laughing)
- So I am like your husband.
- No, he eats
whatever he wants.
It's always a vat of ice cream.
- Have you gotten a Bundt yet?
- No I didn't get
a Bundt yet.
- Aww why'd you bring
it up Chris?
- It's okay.
(laughing)
- It's because it was for my neighbors
and you weren't on this lot.
- Well I actually am your neighbor.
- [Kelly] You are kinda my neighbor now.
- I live so close to here.
- We'll send you a Bundt.
- I'm gonna randomly show
up at your front door
with a Bundt cake and
you're gonna be like,
"Please go away."
- No, no, I'll be like,
"Come on, let's have a
glass of wine, Kelly."
(Kirsten laughs)
- Okay, then I'll hang.
So this is something I find interesting
that I didn't actually
know, you're in a band.
- Yeah.
I knew you were always
kinda cool and rocker 'cause
you always dress cool.
(audience cheers)
(applause)
Explain what kind of music.
- Well I'm performing
under the name Joseph The Spouse.
It's a lot of kind of
country, blues, folk stuff.
- Yes.
- And we just started playing
around Los Angeles and we'll
have an album forthcoming soon.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience cheers)
That's amazing.
(applause)
Is it also because your
co-star's husband, right,
Mandy's husband?
- Yeah, Taylor Goldsmith,
the lead singer and songwriter
for a band called Dawes.
- Dawes, yeah, I know Tyalor.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, oh he's amazing.
- And so he and I
have been writing some songs together.
- Oh that's great, Dawes is great.
- He got the guys together
to come record on the record
and play live out.
- Oh, so this is gonna be
a good record.
- I think so.
- Great.
- I'm excited.
(audience cheers)
(applause)
- So next time you have
to come back and perform.
- Absolutely.
- Okay, I want that.
Well I got a taste of your
singing a few weeks ago.
Just take a look y'all.
(chuckles)
I wanna know 'cause I know
"This Is Us", the show,
but who are (gasps) you?
- That's right.
- Dog or cat person?
- Dog.
- Coffee or tea?
(gasps)
- Coffee.
- Tea.
- Yes, Chrissy for the win.
Can you sing your favorite musical note
in your favorite key?
♪ Middle C ♪
- Can you do it?
- No.
(laughing)
- And good.
(audience cheers)
- That's right.
- Breath support.
(applause)
- That's like crazy Celine Dion power.
That breath support is crazy.
You held it forever.
- I held the note
and it stayed in tune I think.
- No it did
and it was so long.
I was so tired.
- Not a touch of vibrato.
- That actually is harder,
straight tone with no vibrato.
- Thank you Kelly Clarkson.
- That's actually way harder.
(audience cheers)
We would've totally
been choir nerd friends.
I love us.
- Absolutely.
- Okay, okay.
(Chris chuckles)
So you dress like a
rocker all the time too.
He showed up with these
really fly sunglasses
that I wish you would've worn out here.
They're so cool, they're
like steampunk a bit.
- We'll get 'em out here later.
- They're so cool, but you
always have great fashion.
- Oh thank you,
- We have some pictures
actually.
- I appreciate it.
- [Kelly] We have some
pictures that we love.
(audience cheers)
See, check that out.
- Exactly.
Where do you even find
a suit like that?
(applause)
- The top hat.
The top hat.
- You say where do you find
a suit like that, in the
depths of the Internet.
(Kelly laughs)
- Got it, got it.
That makes sense.
(chuckles)
- I have a favorite one though.
We have a favorite one that I love.
(applause)
- Oh wow.
- I'm gonna be real with you,
I didn't know it was you.
- Well good.
(laughs)
If you had recognized me from that,
that'd have been embarrassing.
- No I didn't.
And I would've totally
fanned out even more.
I love "Guardians of the Galaxy".
Have you seen "Guardians of the Galaxy"?
I know I'm a superhero freak.
- I'm not a huge,
this is so funny coming from me.
I'm not a huge superhero fan.
(laughing)
- Well you like one.
- You like Spiderman.
- You like one super--
- Yeah, I like that one.
(laughing)
- I like Batman.
- I'm a freak over it and
I love your Taserface.
- Oh thanks so much.
- That's my favorite
look on you.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- It was such
a great character.
- Thank you.
- So good, you made a villain likable.
(laughs)
- Thanks.
- You made a bad guy good.
- Yeah, he had a dumb face
and a good heart.
(laughing)
(hands clap)
- That was great.
Okay so "This Is Us", Toby.
You now in the show, you're a
new TV dad, you have a baby.
How often do you change the diapers?
- Well luckily on set I
don't have to change any
of the diapers.
- What?
- And when you're a TV dad,
there's multiple children.
We have triplets.
- Yeah, we had twins
on the show that I did.
That looks nothing alike, by the way.
(audience laughs)
There's one scene
and this other shot,
I was like, "Oh god, that doesn't."
(laughing)
Only three babies.
But they're twins, fraternal.
- Because babies can only
work like 13 minutes a day.
- Yeah, it's true.
- I want that schedule.
- Which is an appropriate amount of work
to make a baby do.
(laughing)
- Yeah, agreed.
- 'Cause they didn't sign up.
- No.
(laughing)
- No, I don't change any of the diapers.
- I think that's unfair.
I wanna see an Instagram
of you changing a diaper.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
(applause)
- It's not that hard.
- It seems like calf roping.
- If you have a little boy,
then you gotta make sure
that diaper goes on quick,
let's just put it that way.
- Sure.
- Have you been peed
on in the face, I have.
- I'm sure I have, but I
got that thing on quick.
This is getting maybe a little gross.
- Don't they have little caps?
- They do, I use,
you know those pads when
you're breast feeding,
those little--
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I just use those. (hands
clapping) I just have those
and we slap it on there.
- We just slapped it on there.
- Slap it on there.
- It can get kinda messy.
I want a messy diaper
that you have to change.
That's the kinda friend I am.
- You know what, I'll do it.
- Okay, okay.
Kirsten do you sing to your son?
'Cause you're talking
about you know Dawes,
you know the band, you love music.
- Yes, I do, we sing a
song to him every night,
this Dean Martin song which I keep secret.
It's his lullaby song, but
then my mom sings to him
as soon as she walks in
the door, she's like,
(singing in foreign language)
She's so loud and then she
just repeats and repeats it
and repeats it.
- Does she make up songs?
- Yes with his nickname and she just sings
and she's so loud.
My grandpa, who he's named after,
also Howard is his middle name,
used to sing this song to me.
♪ Kikalina Dunst, Kikalina Dunst ♪
♪ We love you ♪
♪ Kikalina Dunst, Kikalina ♪
So she does that with
♪ Enni Hi P, Enni Hi P ♪
(Chris laughs)
But she's so loud.
- What's Kika?
- Kikalina Dunst.
- Kikalina.
- I don't know, Kikalina.
- She was smoking something.
(laughing)
- She's never tried weed.
♪ Kikalina Dunst ♪
- She was like, "This is
it." ♪ Kikalina Dunst ♪
♪ Kikalina Dunst ♪
- She was probably drunk on whiskey.